the massive agricultural machines are
silently yet powerfully moving across
vast Fields with precise rotations they
cut gather and harvest crops quickly and
efficiently sharp blades slice through
each stock while conveyor belts
continuously move transferring the crops
from the field to waiting trucks these
machines are not just tools but
engineering marbles with unmatched power
and precision the entire field comes to
life rhythmic and vibrant as these
Harvesters turn the heav work of
harvesting into a harmonious stance of
technology and nature thank you for
watching the video and don't forget to
subscribe to the channel for more great
content